proposer est-ce que il était de c'était
une bonne stratégie d'empêcher le débat
d'aller jusqu'au bout alors déjà c'est
un cadre imposé mais que le gouvernement
pouvait modifier moi je n'ai pas arrêté
de le dire jusqu'au vendredi le
gouvernement avait tout à fait le loisir
il y a un décision du Conseil consuel de
1986 qui le dit très clairement de
prolonger le débat au-delà du vendredi
de finir de 3-4 jours nécessaires pour
finir le débat donc il en est
responsable tout comme d'ailleurs je
vous fais remarquer à l'avance il aura
la possibilité au bout de 50 jours c'est
à dire le 16 mars 2 poursuivre aussi le
débat rien n'empêche rien le contraint à
rester dans ce calendrier s'il le fait
pourquoi le fait-il alors est-ce qu'on
peut parler de vous parce que vos
partenaires par exemple un problème
démocratique mais vous avez raison vous
avez raison et on interroge le
gouvernement quand on est face à lui sur
cette stratégie et effectivement il n'a
pas choisi de prolonger comme il aurait
pu le faire maintenant vous avez des
partenaires qui ont un peu tordu le nez
face à votre stratégie
ils ont trouvé que par exemple
Boris Vallot hier dans le Journal du
Dimanche vous l'avez lu député
socialiste qui dit que effectivement
l'anus n'a pas montré son meilleur
visage pendant les débats dit-il nous
devons respecter notre cadre commun nous
en sommes sortis ça ne doit pas se
renouveler de quoi parle-t-il d'une
position commune qui avait été
faite sur le fait de pouvoir discuter de
l'article 7 de pouvoir aller jusqu'à
l'examen de l'article 7 c'était une
position commune vous n'avez pas
respecté ce cadre commun donc c'est un
débat quand même interne vous êtes
contesté sur cette stratégie je vous
interroge sur une stratégie
stratégie je veux dire soit on regarde
les différents statiques parce que pour
moi elle était active de savoir si on
allait ou pas au début de l'article 7 si
on regarde ce qui faisait accord entre
nous ce qui faisait accord entre nous de
toute la nuit Pesse c'était le fait
qu'il était hors de question d'aller
jusqu'à la fin de l'examen de la loi y
compris jusqu'à la fin de l'article 16
dans 4 du calendrier qui nous était
imposé ça c'était un accord global
pourquoi parce que notre notre mission
notre rôle dans l'opposition
contrairement à ce qu'a fait le
rassemblement national qui a tout à fait
joué le jeu du gouvernement c'est pas de
permettre comme ça qu'on passe une loi
en vitesse aussi gramatiques que celle
du projet loi de retraite donc ça ça
faisait accord la différence est
tactique moi je ne suis pas sûr commune
de l'intergroupe c'était de débattre de
débattre de l'article 7 vous n'êtes pas
arrivé à l'article de 3 la position
obstruction
je vous rappelle par exemple que au
moment de l'article 2
le lundi puisque l'article 2 était
examiné la nupesse y compris France
insoumise a retiré tous ses amendements
pour pouvoir accélérer est-ce que les
Allemands
pendant 24 ans on a continué à discuter
de l'article 2 uniquement sur les
amendements de Nice et de la droite
est-ce que vous avez empêché
nous avons joué notre rôle de
parlementaire qui est que quand il y a
une loi de cette importance il est hors
de question la passer en quatrième
vitesse parce que le gouvernement a
décidé ainsi et de toute façon
initiative
donc tout pour nous par exemple sur
l'article 3 enfin la pré-article 2 je
rentre il taille mais qui était
extrêmement important qui était de
montrer par exemple qui avait des
recettes hautes que de faire d'obliger
les gens à travailler deux ans de plus
nous avons estimé oui qu'il fallait
aller au fond du débat et aller au fond
du débat a permis par exemple de révéler
on en parlera après le le comment dire
ce scandale des 1200 euros théoriquement
les questions sur les carrières
en a rendu compte Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
voulait pas qu'on arrive à la situation
qui permettait de voter l'article 7
et sur le projet
loi toute la nuit pêche était d'accord
pour dire que il était hors de question
de faire ce cadeau gouvernement
d'adopter à la va-vite ce projet de loi
de cette manière là vu le temps qu'il y
mettait qui était un parti donc la
différenciation elle était tactique et
si je vous dis ça c'est parce que je le
dis à Boris Vallot comme je le dis à
tous les interlocuteurs qui sont engagés
contre la retraite ne jouons pas le jeu
du gouvernement c'est-à-dire ne
commençons pas à nous envoyer des
petites phrases qui à mon avis sont des
choses qui peuvent se discuter entre
nous moi j'ai aucun problème par rapport
à ça
la place publique des désaccords
on arrête de mettre sur la place
publique des différenciations tactiques
que ce soit entre nous et les syndicats
dans la nouvelle parce que ce qui ne
permettra de gagner le projet de loi de
retraite c'est deux choses c'est le fait
que la grève à partir du 7 mars
fonctionne c'est-à-dire que le pays soit
mis à l'arrêt et c'est l'unité sans
l'unité syndicale qui est vraiment
j'allais dire le 13 il y a longtemps
très longtemps qu'on a pas vu des appels
qui vont de la CGT à la CFDT en passant
par la CFTC les ministres
l'unité de l'animation et comme je veux
gagner je n'alimenterai pas cette
machine à petite phrase qui fait que sur
des questions je vous le dis je
comprends que ça vous fasse pas plaisir
et moi je vous dis pas c'est une
question principale
je dis une chose c'est que quel que soit
l'endroit où on situe et par rapport à
la bataille contre la réforme des
retraites contre cette réforme de
retraite je pense que il faut qu'on se
concentre sur l'objectif qui est que le
gouvernement soit obligé de reculer et
donc l'objectif c'est pas entre nous de
discuter à mon avis de manière assez
simple de nous différents
et les autres mais maintenant je pense
qu'il faut que ça s'arrête et qu'on se
concentre le 7 donc vous regrettez qu'il
est dit ceci il n'est pas le seul les
insultes antennes leur place dans le
débat je regrette mais je ne lui retiens
pas rigueur avec Boris Vallot ça se
passe très bien l'assemblée et avec tous
les députés de la nupesse on a terminé
le vendredi en train d'applaudir tous
Olivier fort qui avait fait une
intervention une fois de plus pour dire
qu'il fallait prolonger le débat sans
aucun problème l'unité doit prévaloir
jusqu'à la fin de la bataille des
retraites les désaccords étalés dans le
départ
les insultes ont-elles leur place dans
le débat
et pardon il a une ancienneté
parlementaire il en a vu d'autres et
bien lui il s'est senti humilié on se
rappelle de sa prise de parole
votre confrère à traiter Olivier notre
collègue qu'a-t-il fait qu'a-t-il fait
il a pris la parole pour dire qu'il
regrettait ce terme c'est quand même
assez rare pour un député et je comptais
j'écoutais Chassaigne applaudi applaudi
de manière importante par la droite et
Renaissance je voudrais dire je voudrais
lui dire à André quand même que il
devrait regarder ce qu'on fait le Parti
communiste dans les décennies passées il
s'apercevrait qu'à certains moments pas
les débats ont été forts alors il y a
des moments où les choses vont trop loin
les choses vont trop loin mais
à part deux trois événements qui ont eu
lieu et qui ont été montés en exergue
parce que c'était un peu aussi le jeu
que vous voulez monter le gouvernement
sur cette question moi je trouve que les
débats ont vu l'ampleur de cette réforme
et l'attaque quelle compte l'attaque qui
est celle de cette rencontre les
Français je trouve qu'on est resté dans
des normes finalement assez assez
débat pour conclure vous n'avez pas
affaibli pardon le
parlementaire
et de discuter en 9 jours d'un projet de
réforme qui condamne les gens à vivre à
travailler deux ans de plus ça oui je
pense qu'ils avaient le Parlement
bonjour Brigitte boucher bonsoir
journaliste à LCP c'est à vous oui
le chef de fil socialiste au Sénat qui a
donné une interview aux échos ce matin
et qui et qui dit que il veut examiner
l'ensemble du texte qui veut aussi aller
à l'article 7 et il revendique le fait
d'avoir déposé 10 fois moins
d'amendement est-ce que pour vous vous
dites la gauche finalement elle se
couche au Sénat non non je me dis pas ça
mais j'aurais juste vous signaler les
choses je pense qu'ils iront à l'article
7 et vous savez pourquoi ils iront parce
que le Sénat ouvre deux weekends de
suite pour le débat est-ce que a refusé
de faire la Présidence de l'Assemblée
le vendredi soir je pense que si on
avait eu trois jours de plus c'est à
dire qu'il correspondaient à la niche
que le Parti socialiste acceptait de
reporter ce qui aurait ce qui nous
aurait fait gagner une journée plus le
week-end on avait les trois jours
nécessaires donc le Sénat pour faire du
Sénat une intelligence le président du
Sénat le président du Sénat a eu
l'intelligence justement d'ouvrir les
weekends ce qui modifient quand même des
choses que ça leur donne deux jours de
débat en plus plein et entier et vous
savez comme moi que traditionnellement
au Sénat mais ça c'est vrai toutes les
lois il y a moins d'amendements c'est
presque une tradition d'abord en
commission il est de règlement les
rapporteurs ont droit de déposer des
amendements donc ça réduit la durée du
débat voilà c'est une autre façon de
faire que que l'assemblée mais moi je
pense que le la gauche j'ai cru le
comprendre d'ailleurs sur le fond va
batailler va se battre mais vous vous
réjouissez du coup qu'elle puisse
examiner l'article 7 je me réjouis
qu'elle ait plus de jours que nous pour
pouvoir le faire
l'article 7 j'ai lu j'ai lu la de la
part de sénatrices communistes le fait
de dire que il se serait fort de ne pas
examiner l'article 7 avant le 7 mars
j'en ai deux d'accord
mais donc de le faire pour pas justement
un moment donné envoyer un signal qui
pourrait être vécu comme négatif si
l'article 7 était voté donc j'ai lu ça
nous on aurait eu je vous le dis nous on
aurait eu le nombre de jours nécessaires
et moi je l'ai redemandé encore une fois
je le disais Elisa et martichou qui me
dit oui mais ça c'est le gouvernement
mais ça c'était important moi j'ai
redemandé jusqu'au bout qu'il dépasse la
date fatidique de 1000 pour aller
jusqu'au bout examiner l'article 7 et
pourtant regardez ce tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon tweet il y a quelques jours
bravo les groupes nubes du Sénat
adoptent la stratégie du groupe LFI à
l'Assemblée pour empêcher le vote de
l'article 7 avant le blocage populaire
du 7 mars Patrick Henner a dénoncé
l'ingérence
vous admettez une forme d'ingérence là
je crois que le droit de dire ce qu'il
pense non c'est un peu nouveau
exagère en parlant d'agence que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a été le candidat enfin le
candidat de la présidentielle en tête à
gauche qui a permis que la nupaisse
existe et permettent ainsi à chacun
d'avoir des groupes importants à
l'Assemblée nationale
disent ce qui à un moment donné ce qu'il
pense sur la stratégie au Sénat enfin
personne est empêchée de parler sur tel
ou telle chose
quand même Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc
Mélenchon voulait pas examiner l'article
7 parce qu'il avait peur que si on était
battu à l'article 7 ça contrecoup
vis-à-vis du mouvement voilà c'est un
choix il l'a dit et cetera est-ce on
peut parler pour autant d'agence et moi
ce que j'observe encore une fois je vous
le dis c'est que le Sénat si j'ai bien
compris ce sera fort de ne pas examiner
l'article 7 avant le que le 7 mars
commence une stratégie divergente en
fait la stratégie différentes mais
est-ce que vous croyez c'est un petit
peu la réponse j'ai fait les auteurs
est-ce que ça c'est très important
franchement j'ai bien compris
je vais aller au fait j'ai compris je
lis les journaux comme vous et cetera et
je vois que alors qu'on prépare une
grève générale le 7 mars de tous les
syndicats que le gouvernement est quand
même très dans une grosse difficulté par
rapport à cette situation on discute de
de des problématiques de la LFI des
problématiques entre la et les filles la
Lupin avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec les
syndicats on discute de tout ça sauf de
ce qui fait le cœur de ce qui se passe
c'est à dire que il y a une unité
syndicale et que toute la nuit
évoquer les stratégies des
parlementaires moi ce qui me paraît plus
important je vais vous dire c'est que
toute la nuit pêche à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat tous les groupes tous les groupes
ok d'accord tous les partis qui
composent la nupes au Sénat et tous les
partis qui composent la nups et la nuit
le plus important c'est que quel que
soit j'allais dire Laurent crache à
gauche ils sont tous pour le projet
retrait du le retrait pur et simple du
projet il soutiennent tous une grève de
fête générale donc grève
interprofessionnelle le 7 à partir du 7
et croyez-moi que dans le passé par
rapport à un projet de retraite ça n'a
pas toujours été comme ça donc moi c'est
ça que je regarde avant tout c'est genre
une autre unité sur des missions
de France insoumise ne sont pas
syndiqués ils ne se font pas se
mobiliser vous croyez que moi je ne vais
pas faire du tout je ne vais pas au
Parlement est-ce qu'il est pas terminé
est-ce que vous avez pas perdu le combat
du Parlement
de toute façon nous n'étions a priori
pas majoritaire au Parlement mais on l'a
pas perdu ce combat le gouvernement n'a
pas pu passer son n'a pas pu faire voter
son projet de retraite comme il avait
pas pu faire voter son son budget alors
ça si ça paraît normal qu'un
gouvernement qui nous dit qu'il est
légitime pour imposer un projet de de
revente soit obligé de s'abriter
derrière 47 ans pour passer en force et
finalement sans vote excusez-moi mais
j'ai pas l'impression que nous perdons
soit et les filles dans l'histoire
[Musique]